well meantime inflation is now the top
issue for voters a new fox news poll
shows 82 percent of those surveyed say
they are extremely or very concerned
about runaway prices let's bring in
maria bartoromo anchor of mornings with
maria on fox business and sunday morning
futures on fox news maria great to see
you i did some research i mean you know
it affects everybody that's why
everybody's concerned about it because
it affects everybody when you're paying
five bucks a gallon for gas out out the
back door here but i want to say that
back in back in may we did some research
the biden white house economic policy
makers federal reserve at that time were
saying inflation was under control and
now four months later it doesn't appear
to be under control
no it's not under control trace thanks
very much for having me this morning
look the bottom line is the federal
reserve and the uh administration have
been saying that inflation pressures are
transitory or temporary we're going to
hear from the federal reserve this week
they have a two-day meeting and they
will answer questions about how
temporary it has been given we are
seeing price spikes on all sorts of
kitchen table items like chicken
commodities the price of lumber has come
down but many expect it to continue
going up uh and resume the spike because
we've got supply disruptions kovit has
shut down a number of uh manufacturing
facilities and that has uh the price uh
being uh pressured higher because you
can't get the supply but i just want to
point to what's going on in the market
today because we have a sell-off
underway the market's going to open in
10 minutes you're going to see the
market open down 600 points why because
there are worries about the impact of a
debt crisis in china there's the second
largest property developer a company
called evergrand and it is missing its
debt payments the ccp has already come
out and said this company will not be
able to pay its debt payments which one
payment is due this upcoming thursday
investors are speculating on whether or
not u.s banks are going to be on the
hook for some of this so beijing has to
make a decision is it going to come in
and save evergrand pay these debt
payments is it going to cherry pick and
and pay other debt payments of other
property developers but evergrand is
china's second largest property
developer and that is what's going on
today and don't forget what's happening
in washington we have nine legislative
days left to deal with the debt ceiling
being raised two massive packages
infrastructure and the reconciliation
package that nancy pelosi wants to see
voted on by september 27th all of that
is playing out in a big way on wall
street today i want to put a couple of
these quotes up these are inflation of
goods since back in january let's run
these down very quickly car and truck
rental up 73 plus percent gasoline up 43
hotels 24 you get the picture here of
what's happening across the country but
here's the news fox news poll conditions
of the economy put this up because this
is back in january 55 percent said yep
excellent or good now that number 30
that is a significant drop and that has
got to be concerning for the biden white
house maria
well look the bottom line trays is the
fact that the definition of inflation is
the following too many dollars chasing
too few goods how many dollars are we up
to the reconciliation package is going
to cost upwards of five trillion dollars
because they've got gimmicks in there
that they say these programs go away
next year meanwhile they're not going
away so it's much more expensive than
the three and a half trillion this is
one reason inflation is taking off we've
got a crisis at the border a crisis in
afghanistan let's hope we are not moving
toward an economic crisis as well
very very quickly lastly maria the u.s
natural gas price is going up i mean
over the past this is i would put this
on the screen as well uh it friday at
five dollars a little over five dollars
per million btus they were about half
that six months ago up 17
this month your final thoughts on this
maria
well this is largely about supply again
when you don't have the supply and
you've got the demand moving up prices
move higher this has been an area that
we're watching because we normally don't
see such moves in natural gas but this
is going to affect your home heating oil
and that's just one more piece of the
puzzle that inflation is hitting us all
on the kitchen table items that we need
to buy every day
and for natural gas this is the off
season imagine what happens as we get
closer to uh fall and winter maria great
to see you as always thank you
you too thank you hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now